So now you've seen that you can encode
4 things in bits.
You can encode any number though, we just need more bits.
So if we have more bits, we can encode more different things.
So here I've got 4 bits.
That means I have 4 yes/no choices,
and I can encode 16 different numbers.
And the reason for that is because 2 to the 4 is 16.
Every time I add 1 more bit,
I double the number of things
because I have 1 more yes/no question.
So for just this part of the graph, I had 8 things.
I have 3 bits.
I could distinguish between the numbers 0 through 7.
Adding 1 more bit
doubles the number of things I can distinguish.
So that's a way to measure information.
And once can distinguish any number of things,
well we can send any kind of data we want.
Anything that's discrete, we can turn into a number.
So we can turn letters into numbers if we have a long string.
We could have a sequence of numbers,
which we can turn into 1 really big number.
So once we can send bits,
we can send anything we want.
So that's what bandwidth is.
It's a measure of the amount of information that we can send,
and we're measuring the number of bits.
Each bit is 1 yes or no decision.
In computing we usually think of that as either a zero or a 1.
So that long string of zeros and 1s is the information we are sending,
and it could be encoding a string of text
like it does in a web page,
it could be encoding an image,
it could be encoding a number.
And to measure our bandwidth, we need to know who many bits
can we send per second.